هل يكفي الاعتذار لطي صفحه حقبه سوداء في
التاريخ الانساني في هولندا قدم رئيس
الوزراء ماركروتا اعتذارا رسميا باسم
الحكومه عن مساهمه الدوله الهولنديه سابقا
في العبوديه
ووصفا روتا العبوديه بانها جريمه ضد
الانسانيه
الاعتذار الهولندي الرسمي كغيره المقدم من
حكومات اوروبيه كان محل جدل قبله خطوه
ايجابيه في حين اكد اخرون انه غير كافر ان
لم يقترن بجبر الضرر عبر دفع تعويضات تحسن
الاوضاع المعيشيه خصوصا في دول مثل
سورينام التي عانى وما يزال كثير من
سكانها اصحاب الاصول الافريقيه من اوضاع
المعيشيه صعبه
في هولندا نفسها راى نواب في البرلمان ان
الخطوه مهمه للمجتمع الهولندي متعدد
الثقافات لمكافحه ظواهر باتلها تاثير سلبي
ملموس كلانقسام والاستقطاب والعنصريه
من اصول المهاجره يملكون منازل اصغر ودخلا
اقل ومستويات تعليم منخفضه وفق تقرير صادر
عن مكتب الاحصاء الهولندي
[تصفيق]
وحكومات زمن الاستعمار في اكثر من مناسبه
ومن اكثر من زعيم
فقبل ايام وصف الرئيس الامريكي خلال
اجتماعه بالقاده الافارقه استعداد
الملايين بخطيئه امريكا الاصليه واشار الى
زمن كانت تجلب فيه النساء والرجال
والاطفال المسروقون مكبلين بسلاسل الى
شواطئ امريكا
وخلال الجوله الملكيه البريطانيه في منطقه
الكاريبي في مرسى دار الماضي تحدث الامير
ويليام عن حزنه العميق بشان العبوديه خلال
كلمه القاها في الجمايكا قبل عام ايضا
اعترفت المانيا رسميا بقتل الالمان سابقا
عشرات الالاف فيناميبيا
وكذلك الحال مع الملك البلجيكي وتعبيره عن
الاسف دون الاعتذار الرسمي لما فعلته
بلاده للشعب الكونغو في افريقيا